le tournant de l'économie française la
liberté des prix invité de notre journal
rené monory nouveau ministre de
l'économie
jacques rue f est mort de poincaré à de
gaulle il a animé l'économie française
les brigades rouges rompent le silence
1/8 communiqué demandent les changes
d'aldo moro contre tous prisonniers
communiste la démocratie chrétienne
refuse sud-liban premières victimes
françaises parmi les forces de l'onu un
casque bleu tué par une mine un monsieur
bonsoir encore les brigades rouges
disent ils en goûte à bout d'un suspense
malsain destinée à faire parler d'eux et
ils réussissent les terroristes italiens
viennent de poser leurs conditions à
l'italie elles ont le mérite d'être plus
claire qu'auparavant la libération de
presse de leurs camarades en échange
d'aldo moro sinon disent les brigades
rouges et bien sinon le président de la
démocratie chrétienne sera exécuté la
réponse des partis politiques à ce
communiqué numéro 8 a été unanime coup
sur coup communiste socialiste et
surtout démocrates-chrétiens ont dit non
rome
victor âme dans le viième message des
brigades rouges il y avait un ultimatum
mais on ne précisait ni le nombre ni les
noms les terroristes dont on exigeait la
libération dans leur huitième message
parvenu ce matin au journal la
repubblica
les brigades rouges réclament la liberté
de 13 terroristes qui se trouvent en
prison
cette fois il faudra bien répondre aux
brigades rouges c'est de nouveau la
tente devant la démocratie chrétienne
puisque dans leur huitième message les
brigades rouges ont bien précisé que
c'est la démocratie chrétienne et son
gouvernement qui devait répondre
nous n'avons pas besoin de médiation
nous n'avons pas besoin d'intermédiaire
disent les brigades rouges les appels de
paul 6 ou de caritas internationalis
sont manipulés par les démocrates
chrétiens
cela dit il y a deux problèmes qui se
posent maintenant le premier c'est que
la démocratie chrétienne a déjà fait
savoir qu'il n'était pas question de
négocier en vue de libérer des
terroristes
le deuxième problème c'est que même si
elle le voulait la démocratie chrétienne
n'auraient pas les moyens d'obliger la
magistrature italienne à libérer des
terroristes
la justice devrait selon les brigades
rouges libéré rester au risque dont le
célèbre renato cours actuellement jugé à
turin qui nargue ses juges derrière les
barreaux d'une cage de fer
son lieutenant alberto franceschini est
également réclamé dans ce huitième
message
mais parmi les treize terroristes il n'y
a pas que des membres des brigades
rouges
il ya aussi des militants des noyaux
armée prolétarien une organisation qui a
pratiqué le hold-up l'enlèvement et
l'assassinât politique dans le sud de
l'italie
les brigades rouges se font-elles
beaucoup d'illusions sur les modalités
d'un échange qui se heurterait à des
difficultés presque insurmontable comme
le précise un journaliste de la
repubblica qui a reçu le message de ce
matin qu'est-ce qu'on veut serein
juridique rien pratiquement rien parce
qu'on devrait passer une loi au
parlement italien il doit qui permettent
la libération de ses prisonniers se peut
ce que vaudrait une volonté politique
évidemment de le faire cette volonté
inapte à l'état pour le moment les
forces politiques des liens pour le
moment du moins ne sont pas disposés à
céder
il faut penser qu'on ne combat vers le
pire
oui et puis à l'instant une lettre de
monsieur aldo moro au quotidien vita en
fait est une lettre adressée au
secrétaire général de sa formation
chrétienne monsieur haqqani sont
contenues disent les journalistes de ce
quotidien romain vite à son contenu
serait bouleversant réunion ce matin du
comité interministériel sur les tarifs
publics qui ne s'agissait de savoir
combien et de combien allait augmenter
les tarifs de l'edf des transports des
ptt et ses vieux raymond barre et ses
ministres sont restés très discrets à
l'issue de ce comité mais on devrait
tous avoir apprennent non au sortir du
conseil des ministres rené monory
ministre de l'économie depuis trois
petites semaines a bien voulu réserver
sa première déclaration radiotélévisée
antenne 2 je remercie monsieur ministre
alors vous ne serez pas d'étonner que je
vous demande d'abord sans être
évidemment indiscrètes de combien vont
augmenter les tarifs dont je parlais je
savais rien n'est arrêté encore nous
avons longuement discuté et je pense que
mercredi vous serez plus informé ainsi
que les français ce sera une grosse
grosse ferden seront un peu plus
importante et d'autres un peu moins
enfin je peux rien vous dire de plus car
rien dans les quartiers où il ya
plusieurs étapes vous verrez le ne me
poussez vos envies retranchements je
suis dans l'impossibilité de vous dire
les décisions n'étant pas encore arrêté
et le second mercredi au conseil des
ministres la wii en a un petit peu
l'impression en ce moment d'une sorte de
réalisation du libéralisme vous
souhaitez une telle me de compétition
certains vont vous dire c'est le retour
à la loi de la jungle les plus faibles
on disparaît on sait pas du tout cela
vous savez que la france est soumise
comme tous les pays d'ailleurs
occidentaux à une nouvelle forme de
concurrence internationale puisque au
cours des dernières années nous avons
beaucoup transférer vers des pays qui
actuellement sa lustré et deviennent
dangereux sur le plan de la compétition
cela veut dire qu'il faut que nous
soyons doté pour faire des richesses
dans les prochaines années d'un outil
économique industriel économie agricole
des sommes importantes compétitif
dynamiques variées pas du tout question
d'employer un mot comme le mot libéral
il est question de transformer une
économie d'assister ou à chaque instant
les chefs d'entreprise demandait à
l'état tendez la main
d'un autre côté il était aussi encadré
sur leurs prix ce qui bien entendu
justifier les interventions mutu de
l'état de transformer cette économie
d'assister en économie de responsabilité
en économie de concurrents et c'est ce
que je me propose de faire avec un
premier ministre dans les prochains mois
c'est une opération difficile car ce ne
sont pas les mesures qui sont difficiles
à prendre des mesures finalement tout le
monde peut les prendre c'est le message
il faut que les chefs d'entreprise de
quelque nature que ce soit sache que
nous leur transfère une responsabilité
dont ils devront faire bon usage
je suis convaincu que l'opération
réussir la première responsabilité c'est
la hausse des prix les prix des produits
industriels elle va commencer quand
cette hausse est elle va cet âge et sur
combien de temps et moins coûteux vous
dire là aussi le calendrier n'est pas
arrêté il y aura plusieurs étapes je
n'ai pas l'intention de libérer tous les
prix le même mois je pense c'est une
opération qui s'échelonnera du 1er
juillet au premier descend par petits
paquets et je suis sûr que là aussi les
chefs d'entreprise montreront de la
raison est que le dérapage des prix
industriels sera peu important et la
gestion pour ce qui rompt trop fort trop
vite et 500 et un vote sanction ayant
des sanctions économiques ce que je
voudrais bien préciser c'est qu'il n'est
pas question de donner la liberté avec
la perspective de la reprendre si les
choses ne vont pas bien c'est une
liberté que je compte donner aux chefs
d'entreprise d'une façon définitive et
sans retour
car si nous disions chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui si vous n'êtes pas salon
vous privera de cette liberté à mon avis
on ne ferait pas une bonne action parce
que on laisserait ce suspense qui
d'ailleurs sans doute déclencherait des
hausses trop fort c'est une liberté
irréversible le patron qui ne sera pas
bien gérer son entreprise qui fera
preuve de laxisme dans la gestion dans
sa masse salariale et laura la sec la
sanction économique c'est-à-dire sans
doute sa disparition c'est ça
véritablement la loi d'un marché qui
croyez moi n'oubliera pas les aspects
humains car n'ayant pas l'intention non
plus comme vous disiez à l'instant
d'établir la loi de la jungle c'est une
économie de liberté de concurrence comme
celle d'ailleurs qu'aegis en allemagne
régime socialiste et maría la liberté
d'être et industriels
y'a comme on l'a dit la vérité des prix
dans les secteurs du tarif public vous
ne serez pas monsieur lundi ça va
beaucoup nous ont fait penser pas que
les lecteurs va vous le reprocher tout
d'un coup on ouvre les vannes après les
élections et vous délaissez faut savoir
ce que nous voulons est ce que la
passion on transfère une responsabilité
aux chefs d'entreprises privées il me
paraît nécessaire de transférer en même
temps une responsabilité aux
responsables des entreprises nationales
je crois qu'il est tout à fait malsain
de faire payer en permanence aux
contribuables et non pas aux
consommateurs
l' équilibre des entreprises publiques
mais bien entendu ces augmentations de
se propres à n'importe quel prix et j'ai
l'intention d'ailleurs au cours des
prochains mois de faire des contrats de
programmes avec les entreprises
nationales de façon à ce que la notion
de gestion comme dans une entreprise
privée soit introduite dans les
entreprises publiques avec de très
grande responsabilité pour leur chef
était probablement ne pas confondre dans
les piles en investissement compte de
gestion
tout cela nous allons y regarder de près
actuellement ces entreprises sont bien
gérées on va leur ajouter encore un peu
quelque chose dans le souci de
responsabilité
ce ministre était avec nous tout au long
cette conversation nous avons souvent
utilisé ce mot de retour à la libye
liberté des prix industriels
alors qu'est ce que cela veut dire dans
la pratique je propose de suivre
l'enquète qu'a réalisé pour nous jean
claude allanic et son équipe
3000 salariés trois usines dont celle ci
à orléans
la cpm est le premier fabricant français
de cuisinière comme tous les fabricants
français la ceppm vit désormais dans la
tente de la libération prochaine
peut être en juillet des prix
industriels une mesure attendue avec
impatience dans ce secteur de
l'électroménager qui s'estiment désarmés
face à la concurrence étrangère par une
réglementation trop sévère car si le
contrôle des prix en vigueur jusqu'à
présent
a réussi à freiner tant bien que mal les
hausses au niveau des consommateurs
les coûts de revient lusine ont
progressé à peu près deux fois plus vite
mais les prix bientôt libéré le danger
c'est bien sûr que tout augmente
pour le pdg de la cmn il y aura certes
des hausses mais il y aura aussi des
baisses prenez par exemple cet appareil
c'est un radiateur un modèle déjà ancien
mais qui plaît toujours
et bien si cela continue je vais est
obligé d'en arrêter la fabrication parce
que ses prix de revient ont grimpé
beaucoup plus vite que les prix de vente
autorisés
alors si j'arrête qui est-ce qui en
profitera c'est la concurrence étrangère
qui elle n'est pas contrôlée qui
toujours prompt à se mettre à notre
place
au contraire si je suis en liberté je
pourrait l'augmenter disons de 5 ou 10%
demain sans que les ventes souffrent
évidemment en prenant le risque qu'un
concurrent me tailler des croupières
mais c'est mon risque et j'en prends la
responsabilité
prenons maintenant cet appareil récent
lui qui est une cuisinière à four
pyrolytique alors là dans le régime
actuel
j'applique vêtements les hausses
autorisée tandis que si c'était dans une
régime de liberté
j'aurais peut-être une stratégie un peu
plus dynamique je rechercherai une plus
grande diffusion de cet appareil en
public quitte à faire souffrir quelques
concurrents et je pourrais par exemple
m'abstenir d'avoir fait la hausse
moyenne de 4% que nous avons fait le 1er
mars
un radiateur qui augmenterait
probablement de 5 à 10% et une
cuisinière qui pourrait baisser de 4 à
5%
le consommateur y retrouvera t-il son
compte il ya fort à parier que la
liberté des prix sera dans une première
étape au moins synonyme de hausse
le problème est de savoir si au bout de
six mois les baisses de prix dues à la
libre concurrence rétabliront
l'équilibré bien je trouve que la
réponse est très claire et de toute
façon il va sans dire que cette liberté
des prix s'accompagnera d'un
développement de la concurrence encore
plus active que maintenant car multicedi
liberté dit absence de protection et
bien entendu c'est dans cette voie que
nous allons nous diriger encore un mot
mais si monory
qu'est ce que ce provincial qui
revendique son provincialisme cet ancien
chef d'entreprise vient au milieu de
tous ces hauts fonctionnaires dont on
dit qu'ils sont redoute alors rivoli et
son redoutable par leur intelligence ils
sont de redoutables également par leurs
chances de l'état car ce sont des gens
extrêmement sérieux qui m'ont toujours
semblé faire bien leur travail et je
constate encore mieux depuis que je suis
à l'intérieur mais ils ne sont pas du
tout redoutable pour le provincial pour
que vous évoquez car j'ai l'impression
qu'au bout de quinze jours trois
semaines
nathan en ce qui me concerne c'est déjà
fait d'être tout à fait bien dans ma
peau
à l'intérieur de cette maison et je peux
vous dire que l'addition du provincial
nos technocrates et la qualité
l'intelligence des hommes qui habitent
la maison ça doit faire je pense une
bonne équipe pour ce qui me concerne je
n'ai pas de problème et j'ai
l'impression que cette équipe est déjà
fait un grand économiste qui vient de
disparaître
jacques rue est spécialiste un discuter
des questions financières et surtout
monétaire par ailleurs membre de
l'académie française et chancelier de
l'institut de france
il s'est éteint hier à son domicile
parisien à l'âge de 81 ans
il avait derrière lui une longue et
brillante carrière puisqu'il avait fait
ses premières armes dans le cabinet de
raymond poincaré il ya plus d'un
demi-siècle
en vérité on ne voit pas qu'il puisse y
avoir réellement de critères des talons
autre que l'or est oui l'europe en 1965
proposé le retour à l'étalon or dans un
monde où triomphe et le dollar c'était
une bombe est en grande partie
c'était l'oeuvre de jacques rue f toute
sa vie il aura défendu cette idée dont
il avait convaincu le général que l'or
était le seul garant possible pour les
monnaies des économies libérales qu'ils
défendent est d'abord polytechnicien
jacques rue f dès 1926 était un
économiste
écoutez dans le cabinet de raymond
poincaré et puis en 44 il devient le
conseiller économique du général de
gaulle qu'il va retrouver en 58 pour
construire avec antoine pinay un premier
plan de redressement
en 1960 il est l'auteur avec louis armes
du célèbre rapport qui porte son nom sur
les causes du blocage économique
après 65 et c'est historique tentatives
pour l'étalon or il ne devait jamais
cessé de dénoncer les vices du système
dollars sévices il se résume en un mot
c'est l'absurdité
nous vivons dans un système futile
absurde qui produit dans tous les
domaines le contraire de ce qu'on attend
de lui
l'étalon or a été définitivement rejetée
en 76 aux accords de la jamaïque le
dollar n'est toujours pas convertible
est aujourd'hui le système monétaire
international et gravement fissuré
monsieur rue f
vous l'aviez prédit premier ministre a
rendu hommage à jacques rue f il a eu le
courage le premier at il dit de
souligner les dangers de la dégradation
du système monétaire international
nouvelles discussions cnpf syndicats
dans trois jours à propos de la pré
retraite et de labellisation du chômage
partiel il s'agit surtout de mise à jour
d'accor ancien une constatation là
encore entre partenaires sociaux sur les
problèmes de l'emploi c'est ce qu'a
annoncé yvan charpentier le présent de
la cgc à l'issue de son entretien ce
matin avec le premier ministre
il ne s'agira pas d'un sommet tripartite
comme le demandaient les cadres mais
d'une procédure qui devrait se terminer
au début de l'automne manifestation
aujourd'hui à fougères dans
l'ille-et-vilaine manifestation
organisée par la fédération régionale du
syndicat des exploitants agricoles est
destinée à attirer l'attention des
ministres de l'agriculture des neuf sur
la situation très difficile des
producteurs français de port et de l'est
il règle depuis ce matin les neuf se
sont retrouvés à luxembourg pour fixer
les prix agricoles européens de la
prochaine campagne
le succès ou l'échec des négociations
dépendra en partie de l'attitude
française pierre méhaignerie via temps
et stand sur bourg avec des demandes
précises sur lesquelles ils semblent
décidés à se montrer intransigeant
france se donne deux objectifs
essentiels
le premier c'est de remédier aux graves
distorsions de concurrence que nous
connaissons depuis quelques mois
quelques années même et pour cela nous
disons que l'augmentation des prix ne
doit pas être la même
par exemple en allemagne ou en france et
dans un dossier difficile comme celui
des montants compensatoires
la seule question que l'on peut poser
est celle-ci
quelle est la capacité d'achat avec un
litre de lait ou un kilo de vue
d'où un kilo de céréales dans les
différents pays européens de
consommation pour les producteurs
agricoles c'est à dire d'andré ou de
machines agricoles
nous avons ce dossier nous avons un
dossier juste que nous défendrons
jusqu'au bout en demandant des
évolutions de prix différentes selon les
pays et enfin une réforme des méthodes
de calcul le deuxième dossier pour nous
c'est de donner aux producteurs la
sécurité m
cornec président la fédération des
parents d'élèves qui porte son nom chez
christian de la khl nouveau ministre de
l'éducation les deux hommes ont convenu
de se revoir on entendrait le maître
cornette dans notre bien lé journal mort
d'un journal le point du jour quotidien
communiste de la région rhône alpes qui
n'a pas su surmonter ses problèmes
financiers
il disparaît quelques mois seulement
après sa naissance violente critique du
philosophe communiste louis althusser
contre les méthodes de fonctionnement du
pc il s'agit de la première partie d'un
article publié par le monde est intitulé
ce qui ne peut plus durer dans le parti
communiste et le propose surprend par sa
force
louis althusser va plus loin encore que
l'historien jean lenten que nous avions
interviewé il ya soit 20 journal ils
reprochent à la direction du parti
commises tout à la fois ses déclarations
au lendemain du scrutin
le refus de la discussion dans la presse
du parti et puis le manque de dialogue
entre la base et les dirigeants
l'expérimentation d'une bombe à neutrons
français ce n'est pas sérieux a dit ce
matin le porte-parole de l'elysée aucune
expérience de ce genre n'a eu lieu et
aucune n'est programmé un casque bleu
français tués par une mine au sud liban
c'est le premier français à mourir pour
essayer avec les troupes de l'onu de
faire respecter le cessez-le-feu entre
israël et palestiniens et on ne connaît
pas encore son nom ce premier casques
bleus français au liban faisait partie
des 11 100 soldats de métier france est
cantonné à tyr et participant aux forces
déployées par les nations unies au sud
liban
hier soir une patrouille française a été
pris sous le feu croisé d'éléments
palestiniens et israéliens
en rentrant au poste ce casque bleu
auraient sauté sur une mine dans un
secteur à l'est de tirs dans cette
région la tâche des soldats de l'onu est
particulièrement délicate et casques
bleus sont au centre des conflits
entre factions libanaises chrétiens et
palestiniens ou palestiniens et
israéliens
aux termes d'une résolution de l'onu de
mars dernier
les israéliens devraient évacuer
totalement le sud-liban en fait à la fin
du mois ils n'auront libéré que 65% des
territoires qui les occupent
l'accord signé hier à beyrouth entre les
principaux courants politiques libanais
accord qui prévoit notamment la
suspension de toute activité armée
palestinienne ou autres au liban
pourraient permettre de former un
nouveau gouvernement libanais est
peut-être d'atténuer quelques temps les
antagonismes un autobus des tournées en
afrique du sud 42 passagers à bord il a
été détourné par des guérilleros ce
nationaliste noir et aurait été conduit
en angola grande de la ville amorena
c'était les premiers accents d'une
chanson diffusée il ya tout juste quatre
ans à la radio portugaise à la première
heure du 25 avril 74
cette chanson jusqu alors interdite
donné le signal de la révolte des
capitaines destinée à renverser le
successeur de salazar depuis le régime
démocratique portugais a fait son
apprentissage et c'est vrai qu'à
lisbonne il règne un petit air de
liberté
mais c'est vrai aussi il faut le dire
que tout n'a pas été réglé pour autant
et surtout pas les problèmes économiques
la situation là bas est devenue
dramatique le portugal est parvenu en
quelques années en tête du hit parade du
chômage et surtout de l'inflation un
reportage de serge me serais et des gens
à lisbonne aujourd'hui en manifestent
contre la vie chère
tout augmente à une vitesse folle le
pain l'huile le sucre le riz 22% de plus
depuis le début du mois les services
publics le gaz l'eau l'électricité de 25
à 50% les impôts majoré de 15% le pays
accumule les superlatifs plus fort taux
d'inflation et de chômage européen
un travailleur sur trois sans emploi
alors la ménagère sort de sa cuisine
pour descendre dans la rue et exigé que
son filet à provisions 16 de mégrit
ainsi fernanda puéricultrice dans une
école de la banlieue de lisbonne
marié un enfant tous les trois jours
environ
elle va au marché et malgré des
acrobaties financières n'arrive pas à
s'en sortir
ainsi explique-t-elle le prix du bifteck
est passé du simple au double ainsi que
la volaille en moins d'un mois
combien ça coûte aujourd'hui de faire un
marché et qui à chaque côté il ya six
mois
bien il y a 6 mois il fallait princesse
khoudoss environ 60 francs pour faire un
bon marché aujourd'hui avec me laisse
rudolph et en faisant bien attention ça
ne suffit pas sebastian le mari de
fernanda travaille au chantier naval de
setubal à 40 km de là tous les matins un
but cela mène à son travail
un but dont le tarif vient d'augmenter
de 25%
sebastian est l'un des six mille
employés de cette manne il était soudeur
mais comme il a eu un accident on la
recaser dans la formation
professionnelle
cette nav
c'est le plus grand chantier naval du
portugal et peut-être même d'europe
construit en 72 nationalisé en 75
l'ultra moderne peut fabriquer des
pétroliers allant jusqu'à 320 milles
tonnes largement subventionnés par
l'état
et comme beaucoup d'entreprises au
portugal en déficit 3 millions et demi
de francs 76 4 millions et demi en 77
mais il n'y aura pas de licenciements
les accords avec les syndicats
l'interdît les ouvriers de cette nav
on les plus forts salaires du portugal
1200 francs par mois contre six ans dans
les autres secteurs
sebastian lui gagne péniblement 1000
francs par mois
sa femme travaille elle apporte 600
francs de plus dans la cagnotte du
ménage mais ça ne suffit pas pour
joindre les deux bouts
non c'est pas suffisant
ça m'a poussé son fils en tournant pour
manger il mal mais il faut qu'on
continue comme ça je sais pas combien de
temps nous on fait ça on a on pense que
qui aura des jours meilleurs quoi que ça
viendra je vous sens viendra meilleure
et j'ai pas faire en liberté et manger
un petit peu plus - est révolue at il
asséné un bon les autres je sais pas
qu'est-ce que les incidents tout à
l'heure devant l'église arménienne de
paris des arméniens qui voulaient
commémorer l'anniversaire de leu leu du
génocide de leur club par les autorités
turques en 1915 se sont heurtés à la
police parce que la manifestation était
interdite et forces de l'ordre ont alors
chargé et on a interpellé une dizaine de
personnes plusieurs milliers d'arméniens
assisté pendant ce temps une messe à
l'intérieur de l'église
autre anniversaire les trente ans d'une
organisation religieuse humanitaire aide
à l'église en détresse est un organisme
toujours très attentif aux problèmes des
persécutions dans les pays de l'est
à titre d'exemple ils distribuent des
bibles en russe derrière le rideau de
fer mais ces activités ne se limite pas
à cela il faut dix harkis n'a les moyens
tout a commencé il y a trente ans dans
sept grandes abbayes de la flandre belge
à l'intérieur de ses murs un jeune moine
le père vérone fried a entendu parler de
l'immense misère des réfugiés en
allemagne
parmi ces personnes déplacées plus de 8
millions de catholiques avec leurs trois
mille prêtres
il manque touche du strict nécessaire
le père vérone fried les nourrit les
habits effet affrêté pour eux ces
camions chapelle qui le feront connaître
la situation évolue jusqu'aux années 50
peu à peu les réfugiés regagnent leur
pays pays que yalta a placé souvent
derrière le rideau de fer
les chrétiens de l'est affirme être
l'objet de persécutions le père vérone
free mobilise l'opinion l'argent afflue
et l'aide à l'église en détresse par le
canal des banques internationales
financent en tchécoslovaquie en pologne
et ailleurs des constructions d'églises
semblable à celle de nova uta que l'on
peut voir ici
les critiques n'ont pas manqué l'aide à
l'église en détresse est qualifiée
parfois d'entreprise à fabriquer de
l'anti communisme primaire nous ne
regardons pas exclusivement dans une
seule direction en amérique latine j'ai
constaté que la menace vient de deux
côtés des capitalistes qui veulent que
le peuple reste pauvre et ignorant afin
de maintenir leur pouvoir des
communistes qui ont besoin de la misère
comme locomotive de la révolution et qui
sabotent toute tentative de solution
j'ai compris que l'église doit défendre
contre la droite et la gauche
l'image de dieu dans d'un million de
sous-alimentés et d'analphabètes
350 camions acheté à l'armée suisse et
rééquiper deux millions six cent mille
dollars recueillis le projet amas de
l'aide à l'église en détresse en
amérique latine contribuer c'est sûr à
sortir bien des gens de l'isolément et
de l'exploitation mais une question se
pose une organisation charitable devenu
une grosse affaire au nom de
l'efficacité et maniant par le fait même
des fonds considérables dans des
structures de plus en plus nombreuses ne
risque-t-elle pas de perdre un peu
l'esprit de ses débuts on redécouvre les
vertus du lait naturel je parle de celui
là couché longtemps en effet on avait
prôné les avantages du lait artificiel
mais il est à l'étape d'un colloque qui
s'est déroulé tout le week-end à monte
carlo sous patronage d'ailleurs d'une
marque de lait en poudre ont prouvé que
rien ne valait le lait des jeunes mr
mourinho
les maternelles puisque le lait en
poudre invite le lait maternel déjà bien
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait là prévient
qu'elles sont retrouve en fait le
meilleur produit qui existe au monde il
a été sélectionné au cours de l'histoire
des mammifères sur 500 millions d'années
et pour nous bien millions d'années
alors en un million d'années il a retenu
tout ce qu'ils avaient bien on a besoin
de tout et de rien d'autre
les dosages sont bien on a des sucres
des grès des protéines des vitamines des
sels minéraux exactement ce qui convient
pour le petit d'homme jour après jour
selon l'avait un peu oublié
alors on l'avait un peu oublié que
j'avais surtout oublier une deuxième
chose parce que le vivront c'était assez
commode de temps en temps mais c'est que
le lait maternel contient aussi des
armes formidable pour lutter contre
toutes les infections
alors les pédiatres réunis à monte carlo
du monde entier il n'y avait pas
seulement des français ont beaucoup
insisté en particulier pour les premiers
jours de la vie à ce qu on re découvre
le l'interpellent parce que c'est
vraiment le meilleur pour le p'tit dop
ayant dit que les play-offs en savent
plus que ce soit c'est un style alliant
une enquête qui montre que actuellement
une femme sur deux allaite son enfant -
une semaine mais qu'une femme sur deux
n'a jamais vu à l'été et puis que les
petites filles ça puisque c'est qu'un
sale femme et sa cette veine noté
anormal sa vie on imite bien le lait ah
oui alors comme à l'aller vertueux oui
on le l'industriel a des tas de vertu et
on va pas dire d'un seul coup que tout
le monde doit l'été d'abord c'était une
décision personnelle qui les avantage
psychologique mais qui a aussi des tas
d'inconvénients sur le plan social
et puis l'industrie à flâner dans mes
fort et là on recommande beaucoup les
laits maternisés
les dérivés du lait de vache mais qui on
est et humaniser rendit le plus près
possible des dosages humain car ils
n'ont pas les armes de défense du lait
humain mais il s'en rapproche beaucoup
l'année conseil martin de 0,1 en oui
alors de ce qu'il faut sur un tableau
avec une nouveauté c'est à dire que de 0
à 4 mois on recommande le lait maternel
ou lé maternisé et puis après ce qu'on
appelle un lait de suite qui va sortir
bientôt sur le marché et qui sera
enrichie en fer parce qu il semble qu'on
manque de fer après six mois j'adore
déjà vous donner un rendez vous ferai
demain soir 22h15 c'est à dire après le
match bastia eindhoven question de temps
avec la diffusion d'un reportage
passionnant sur les pyrénées atlantiques
deuxième volet d'une série que nous
avons intitulé quelle france d'ailleurs
jean pierre elkabbach et louis blériot
était tout à l'heure à pau pour
présenter ce sujet en avant première aux
palois directement concernés donc
mercredi
22h15 auparavant prochain rendez vous
avec l'information 22h55 avec gérard
holtz la météo de demain quand même sur
la moitié nord du pays le ciel sera
nuageux avec de faibles plus en bretagne
sur la normandie sur la moitié sud temps
instable accompagné d'averses de
l'aquitaine à la provence peu devant la
situation sur le front de la marée noire
n'évoluera donc guère
et ça devrait permettre aux responsables
de continuer à bien travailler de
nombreuses plages surtout dans les côtes
du nord sont maintenant très propre et
il ne devrait pas y avoir de problème
pour la saison touristique d'été je dis
cela parce que trop de vacanciers se
sont décommandés
alors que les hôteliers tous les bretons
sont prêts à les accueillir dans de très
bonnes conditions
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention et je souhaite vous retrouvez
demain au revoir